welcome everyone to a brand new show get
excited for a brand new show smash your
heart is broke face for brand new show
introducing cringe to States cringe
Tuesday's everybody let me know if
you're excited brand new show let's just
jump into it it's the same concept as
any other video crease Tuesdays let's go
check Madison Brookes recording I'm not
getting any phone it works yeah life
sometimes sounds good now that I'm
starting to do live stream this is a
perfect example for me to learn what not
to do there's good lord no sign I need
the training therefore we can watch
these news anchors fails crazy Tuesday
Prince Tuesday let's go that clock why
is there not blood on that this is so
obviously fake okay don't make me laugh
I want the pure cringe come on when
people saying dumb SH so the Dalai Lama
walks into a pizza shop oh my god Pizza
yeah pizza pizza shop and says can you
make me one with everything
what's that
he doesn't speak English why would he
understand your joke Jesus Christ what's
the point so dumb you know what I mean
do you know what I mean can you make me
one with everything
no offense I'm sure it's a great guy but
this is kind of person that in real life
in real life no one these people I make
these awful jokes and you're just for
the sake of politeness you laugh along
you go haha
that's that's funny one with everything
and you go about your day but in reality
no no one likes your joke
I'll all have that disconnect now thanks
to the Internet it just becomes pure
cringe so many things that previously
God God uh troubling snow in dealing
with the bitter cold are you dreaming of
fishing or boating ah yes that sounds at
least the boating part sounds good you
can get a taste of summer this weekend
at the State Fairgrounds especially if
you're the outdoorsy type I'm Stephanie
so VR and coming up Tuesday
this is what I've been saying all along
women can't drive that's right why do I
make this ironic takes you know
someone's gonna make a compilation out
of it eventually and be like look well
if you do this by sickle women bicycle
what is this video
bah bah bah dah dah you can't argue with
the facts and logic those little guys
are cute and cuddly looking and the
Beavers I've seen are bigger and not
yeah and they don't look as friendly so
I don't know maybe I've seen my beavers
in the wrong place that's funny
come on I want some cringe man it's
cringe Tuesday's god dammit just show me
[Music]
cringe
Tuesday's please cringe I just wanna
cringe is that too much to Fripp an ass
dude suppose every demand for nail on
squawking he did seal comfort welcomed a
language oh my god he's using the metal
to save her
haha ramen fools income he just goes oh
let me save her with my giant metal here
you go
greenish Tuesday's green Tuesday girls
were completely engrossed by it when we
were watching it it really does make you
feel like you're inside this eleven year
old girl god damn it
the people not hear themselves speak I
love that when someone says something
completely innocently but the person
listening and goes like oh god why did
my brain go there in a profoundly
wholesome way it's according to Oxfam of
the world's 85 richest people is equal
to the three and a half billion poorest
people it's fantastic and this is a
great winning because it inspires
everybody gets the motivation to look up
to the 1% and say I want to become one
of those people I'm gonna fight hard to
get up to the top this is fantastic news
and of course I applaud it 85 people
have all the will need someone to look
up to know is it better for me to
double-fist it or should I do one utter
at a time I am being a beginner keep
that in mind
I apologize to every goat farmer out
there that thinks and every ex-boyfriend
I want the cringe man I'm just laughing
this is not try not to laugh give me
some
okay
oh no hoo-ha let him hear himself get
caught
God Texas senator Ted Cruz Oh
ah
go just go Oh God
Florida Senator Marco Rubio whoever
might not see this oh my god it's
something totally like don't worry about
it I'll call your name
former Florida Governor Jeb Bush and
there they are then there with two oh my
god that is amazing Hey look at him look
at this guy what are you doing idiot
haha I don't know anything about this
man I don't know anything about his
politics but at least he seems like an
honest person if we're not going it
seems like he would follow roots at the
very least I mean that's that's a good
quality right all right Sally thank you
and to find which sunscreen is best for
your skin five ways to keep your family
safe from the Sun check out the top leg
on the pittsburgh channel it's on the
left-hand side of the homepage I want
whatever you're using it's the best
reply I've ever heard yeah that's great
ten out of ten responds yeah great
Tuesday
Greg dared a Wendy Williams under the
influence on her live TV show now I
haven't watched this and I don't like
Wendy Williams so immediately I know I'm
gonna like this
but at the second say on another point
of view yeah I thought about how
soul-crushing it must be to do those
daily shows what it's all about so happy
and like I would [ __ ] get smashed too
if I had to do that what she had to do
so we'll watch days blac Chyna
is suing Kardashian's forgetting her
show can't she's blaming them because
allegedly there were emails alleging
that Khloe highly we emails alleged
relationship good deliberate just wants
publicity jr. thing and even promised
the Kardashians would film extra
episodes to make up for the cancellation
of the time and black show I will do
what you want
Khloe allegedly said that she was
concerned for their brands I can't watch
this Oh cringe to say everyone smash
like subscribe have you not subscribed
yet subscribe for Tim's new date or else
there will be consequences I am
apparently Wendy Williams I can't speak
thank you guys for watching another
video see you tomorrow and as always
have a wholesome life and I see you
never
hi tuber simulator it's now so relevant
that it's got a brand new minigame
crania
drop the crane and get fresh items only
available in the washing machine like
game and you say there's more of course
there is new knowledge perks new quests
and new pics links and legs guys leg